bîmes regarder ce que jean recevoir les
amis petit cadeau de 1 gromard si vous
avez une excellente mémoire vous vous
souvenez de ce que 5 romain ce petit
test de daltonisme que j'avais fait ce
qui est cool c'est qu'à la suite de
cette vidéo il ya eu déjà beaucoup de
gens qui sont allés faire le test
d'atonie sur le site donc un chrome a
repéré qui avait des mouvements ils ont
trouvé ma vidéo et ils m'ont proposé de
m'envoyer des lunettes qui corrige en
quelque sorte mon daltonisme
souvenez-vous moi je suis dotée rano mal
parce que c'est le vert que je vois mal
et ceux qui voit mal le rouge sont des
pros tanoh mal mais aussi ceux qui voit
mal le bleu qui sont d'être hitano mal
c'est compliqué bref il ya différentes
l'une est selon votre type de dalle
tenue si aussi des daltoniens qui voit
qu'une seule couleur et le monde est
hyper fade pour eux et ses lunettes leur
permet de le voir un peu plus comme les
gens normaux à l'action ça corrige pas à
100%
ta vision sénia je vais pas voir à 100%
comme quelqu'un qui n'est pas daltoniens
même plus que moi en fait mon à tunis
mais assez léger je me demande si ça va
vraiment modifier la perception des
couleurs et si c'est le cas je me
demande ce que les gens normands voient
en fait parce que je pensais pas que
c'était un vrai handicap en fait je
n'avais pas calé que j'étais vraiment
daltoniens français j'avais une petite
défaillance mais pas que c'était du
daltonisme ouais c'est naïf ou avait
clairement je les ai alors celle ci
c'est des lunettes d'extérieur c'est à
dire qu'il faut les utiliser en
extérieur quand il fait assez soleil
c'est le cas aujourd'hui on a de la
chance alors il faut savoir que ça
marche pour quatre personnes sur cinq
20% conscient des gens il faut aussi
savoir que quand je vais les mettre les
faits ne sera pas immédiat déjà j'aurai
un style énorme ça ce sera immédiat par
contre je me fais ça prendra entre 10 et
15 minutes et j'espère ne pas être la
personne sur cinq chez qui ça marche pas
[ __ ] ça me ferait chier je vais aller
dehors et j'ai acheté tout simplement
des fruits et des légumes de couleurs a
comme par exemple une pomme
voilà ou encore une tomate parce que
c'était un objet dont tout le monde
connaît la couleur et dont la couleur
est assez pétantes donc je pense que ça
peut être un bon test dernières infos
avant d'y aller que je trouve assez ouf
en fait les hommes ont un seul
chromosome x ça vous savez et les femmes
en ont deux et en fait c'est ce
chromosome x qui est porteur du gène du
daltonisme du coup il ya un mec sur
douze sur la planète qui est daltonien
et une fille sur deux sens qu'il est
donc une fille vu qu'elle a deux
chromosomes x
et ben si l'un est atteint et porteur du
gène pardon le deuxième lui et safe et
du coup bah elle verra les couleurs
normalement mais il arrive que les deux
soient porteurs du gène et du coup dans
ce cas là bas la fille et daltonienne
donc rien qu'en france on a à peu près
65 millions d'habitants ça fait qu'il ya
trois millions de daltoniens d'après les
statistiques et je suis persuadé qu'il y
en a plein qui ne savent même pas voilà
c'était moment mathématiques ces moments
statistiques il est temps d'aller
essayer ça je vais sur la terrasse
ok aux lyonnais sur la terre sont allés
dehors parce qu'il a plu à tous cas vois
pas pourquoi je dis à terra je suis
débile attention parfois que je l'aimais
c'est parti je sors dans les yeux en
train de se battre et c'est trop bizarre
c'est comme s'il y avait un filtre rose
telles qu'elles sont un peu trop
puissance par rapport à ma vision c'est
peut-être pour ça que j'attends 10 15
minutes
l'effet des couleurs et pas immédiats en
revanche l'effet du style lui est
immédiat 18h12 disons qu à 18h22 je
pense que je suis complètement habitué
ces foutus de ma gueule de mariano
rigolant le mec se moque d'un handicap
aequo avec j'ai l'impression de voix
juste mal le vert mais j'ai l'impression
que on a mis la tasse sur un logiciel de
montage et qu'on a augmenté la
saturation un peu c'est trop bizarre que
tu jures mec j'ai un choc on a vraiment
pin pelles et la saturation
c'est ouf on vient de passer devant le
rayon gel douche et en fait j'ai bloqué
parce que je quittais grave différents
moyens des couleurs où j'arrive à
différencier mais la différence est
moins flagrante en fait les autres ça ça
mais j'ai un sou que j'ai légèrement de
trucs et y en a qui l'ont plus ou moins
de force et je pense que les lunettes
elle corrige pour les gens qui l'ont
assez fort peut-être pour ça que je vois
vraiment la différence entre les trucs
genre abusent c'est pas bon ça
fonctionne plutôt et bien vous n'avez
pas plutôt vite notre plutôt vite âge
auquel franck et alors
ça fait actuellement 13 minutes que j'ai
les lunettes j'ai trouvé une appli qui
va me permettre de vous montrer ce que
je vois - habituellement parce que là on
fait juste en train de gérer je vois
plus colorés je pense qu'à plus
intéressants comme vidéo en gros je vois
beaucoup plus coloré quand j'étais jeune
sonia plus de contraste et saturation
mais y'en as limite trop en fait je
pense que les lunettes corrige le défaut
de vision diverses que j'ai un peu trop
fort pour moi moi je dois avoir le
problème mais pas à ce point en fait bon
c'est quand même cool parce que ça me
permet de différencier le gris et le
rose facilement tout comme le rouge le
jaune et le orange au supermarché avait
un caddie rouge et un gamin et qu'un sac
orange et à côté ça m'a frappé la
différence comme les gels douche
j'arrive vraiment un bien différencier
tout on va rentrer et on va essayer de
regarder des fruits des légumes voir si
ça me paraît un peu plus ouf
mais en gros mais je vois un peu trop un
peu trop coloré je trouve et il m'a mis
une sorte de mini voile rose
donc ça marche mais ça marche trop je
vais tester ça s'appelle les sens pour
toi ce que tu vas voir ouais c'est pas
rose est ce qu'on peut dire qu'ils
voient la vie en rose fantastique nattes
ou s'il vous plaît mais moi ça va alors
là tout tient du coup jeté sur une vidéo
où j'étais des lunettes anti la tenue je
vois des couleurs c'est énorme
avant je voyais tout en noir et blanc
jaune énorme énorme jeter ses lunettes
ciao à bientôt dans toutes les couleurs
merci
les amis je viens de lancer
l'application chromatique 'vision
simulator en gros ça va nous permettre
de voir des objets comme une personne
normale les voies puis ensuite de les
voir comme un 2 tera normal les vois
comme un triste j'ai oublié le nom par
exemple ou à m ce truc rose et ce truc
rouge à côté et voilà voici comment
quelqu'un normal les voir aux échos mans
1-2 terra nova donc ce que j'ai des voix
en bas alors bien évidemment c'est
totalement abusé genre mais moi le truc
du bas je le vois mais carrément des
coloristes très bizarre mais
effectivement je vois les couleurs un
peu moins flashy maintenant je pense
qu'un symptôme quoi j'ai gardé une et
c'est là mais j'ai largué les fruits et
légumes entre en jeu par exemple une
merveilleuse barquettes de gariguettes
on connaît bien explications en images
attention mais voilà comme vous pouvez
voir en bas bon moi c'est pas à ce point
encore une fois mais elles sont moins
flashy tout simplement plus vite suivant
la carotte à c'est moins flagrant sur
une carotte c'est moins rouge
ok fruits suivant tomates excellent
c'est une grande surprise ça perd de son
éclat
suivant le risque est bien sûr mon g5
basket par jour est bien mais qu elle
est beaucoup moins eux elle est beaucoup
moins flashy mais mais souffrait du
moment que c'est alors à temps la pâtée
pour chat attends t'es pas en train de
kanata sont produits dans ma vidéo en
scred je vais te défoncer oui suivant
bon à une pomme toute verte sans
surprise ça va apparaître assez - versé
moins vers logique veut qu'on perd la
perception de faire aboutir du coup
c'est ça devient encore légèrement
orangée c'est très drôle
c'est amusant ce qu'on fait c'est non
mais bon on est amis et écouter je crois
qu'on a fait le tour de la petite est
contagieux 1 606 fait le mec
ah oui je veux bien accessoire déjà
acheté [ __ ] go up la magie du montage
c'est énorme
un gant rose commence avant la gorge
rose et ben voila ca père pareil de son
éclat de haut bref j'espère que ces
vidéos vous aura intéressé les amis
jouent juste alors ah oui à la mecque
bon c'est un peu comme pourquoi j'ai
demandé aux mecs le mois sur le don de
me kadri pour cette vidéo on te voit
as tu crois être caché on te voit eh ben
les investis afin de céder aux peurs
qu'elle vous a plu ces cas n'hésitez pas
à aller mais comme d'habitude je tenais
vraiment à essayer ses lunettes en vrai
comme vous alors je n'allais pas avoir
une réaction abusé comme oui parfois sur
internet certaines personnes qui eux
voient par exemple qu'une couleur ou
deux couleurs ou quand il met le
les lunettes il découvre vraiment des
couleurs ou là ils sont ils pleurent
carrément tellement ils sont heureux moi
j'ai pleuré juste parce que maxence est
beau mais sinon j'ai pas pleurer si vous
êtes daltoniens un peu violent je vous
invite à acheter sur le net parce que
vous serez vraiment surpris si vous
aussi vous avez comme moi un très léger
truc vous avez pas besoin franchement ça
coûte un peu cher par rapport à à
l'effet que savons-nous axa au procureur
moi je donne des bons tuyaux ouais je
t'ai de chèques leurs beaux jours merci
d'avoir vécu ce moment avec moi merci
maxence devoir recadrer et puis écouté
ta gueule on se retrouve une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien et puis il va
s'en est fini de ces histoires de
couleur on a fait le tour
make supporter vous avez sûrement vu que
j'en fasse le test data nice mais hélas
ça ne marche pas ça ne corrige pas ses
sabres faire le test je verrai toujours
pas les chiffres
voilà je vous fais un maximum de bisous
je voudrais être une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien et n'oubliez pas de
manger cinq fruits et légumes par jour
c'est hyper important et de pâtée pour
chat aussi par jour ça va un port pour
votre chat bien sûr allez on va manger
des fraises au soleil c'est la belle vie
en ce moment la vie
[Musique]